anti-terror investigators in London are
searching more locations for ties to
Saturday's deadly attack people across
Britain pause this morning to honor the
seven people killed officers on the
street you can see bowed their heads and
commuters paused in train stations all
across the country two more of the
victims have been named by their
families James McMullen and Christi
Bowden and police just identified the
third of the three attackers as Yousef
Zomba who they believe is an Italian of
Moroccan descent one of the other two
suspects was a familiar figure to police
Charlie d'Agata is on London Bridge
where the attack began Charlie good
morning good morning well people are
still laying flowers here at the scene
of the attack through the pouring rain
but revelations that one of the
attackers was known to British police
and intelligence agencies are turning
feelings of agony into anger they knew
his face they knew his name karim but 27
years old a father of two a british
citizen born in pakistan the alarm bells
should have been deafening he had even
appeared on a documentary last year
called the jihad ease next door seen
praying near an Isis flag butts alleged
to have been an associate of convicted
British hate preacher on John Chowdhury
it goes further his neighbors reported
him to an anti-terror hotline gibreel
paloma said he was worried but was
radicalizing kids saying things like and
if you are not Muslim you don't follow
in the religion of Muslim basically
France
you're basically going to help
counterterrorism police said he had been
investigated but there was no evidence
he was planning a deadly suicidal
assault a second name suspect 30 year
old Rashid Redwan claimed to be Moroccan
and Libyan he was not on police radar
more information is emerging about
Saturday night's attack British media is
reporting a dozen Molotov cocktails were
discovered in the back of the van that
mowed down pedestrians that night the
victims of the attacks were honored at a
vigil Monday evening in London AM
James McMullen whose sister Melissa said
he works seven days a week to give his
family a better life
he was always exhausted to do this for
my family
Melissa McMullen said Schilling found
out that her brother was a victim after
they found his bank card on one of the
bodies days after the attack there is
still a number of people listed as
missing and still a number unidentified
gal so so painful to see thank you very
much Charlie d'Agata reporting from
London this morning